Ottawa demande aux patient qui souffrent
de maladies mentales et qui souhaitent
se tourner vers l'aide médicale à mourir
d'attendre encore
devait leur donner accès à ce soin de
fin de vie à compter du 17 mars prochain
le ministre l'amitié prolonge le délai
d'un an médecin psychiatre ne sont pas
prêts selon lui on veut d'abord que le
système de santé dans toutes les
provinces reçoivent des consignes et des
normes claires pour adminer pour
administrer l'aide médicale à mourir
dans des circonstances difficiles et
complexes le député bloquiste Lucario
fait partie du comité d'élus qui s'est
penché sur la question et qui a déposé
un rapport au ministre en juin dernier
selon lui cela aurait été une erreur
d'aller de l'avant on n'est pas
convaincu de
l'avancée des travaux sur le terrain
pour faire en sorte que tout se passe
correctement ça va beaucoup trop vite sa
collègue conservatrice est encore plus
inquiète on n'est pas prêt on sent qu'on
projet et
je le sens aussi au niveau de mon caucus
la question est délicate et divise aussi
le monde médical
sur deux qui est pas tout à fait
d'accord et ça fait pas non plus un
large consensus dans population donc il
faut informer il faut former il y a pas
un seul médecin qui va accepter de
donner l'aide médicale en mourir un
patient qui a un problématique depuis un
an ou deux le numéro chirurgien George
l'espérance est président de
l'Association québécoise pour le droit
de mourir dans la dignité il administre
l'aide médicale à mourir est-ce que moi
je me sentirai à l'aise tout comme mes
collègues pour les problématiques de
santé mentale oui en notant que nous
avons
un suivi psychiatrique et de
multidisciplinaire en santé mentale et
que nous avons donc un dossier très très
solide sur le plan de l'évaluation et du
suivi il comprend cependant que le
gouvernement veuille prendre le temps de
bien faire les choses il est prêt à
attendre mais pas plus qu'un an c'est
vraiment plus une joute politique
satisfait sur le dos des patients
actuellement l'avocat Jean-François
Leroux considère que les patients eux
ont suffisamment attendu à quoi va
servir
la prochaine année de réflexion si ce
n'est peut-être que de tenter de rallier
politiquement certains opposants le
gouver au Pays-Bas où elle est offerte
depuis maintenant plus de 20 ans la
maladie mentale représente moins d'un
pour cent des demandes ici Valérie
Gamache Radio-Canada
Ottawa